before you start listening to this
podcast we've got a special subscription
offer you can get 12 issues of The
Spectator for 12 pounds which will give
you full access to everything on our
website and we'll also throw in a free
20 pound Amazon voucher just go to
spectate code at UK forward slash
voucher if you'd like to get this offer
welcome to a new spectator podcast I'm
Fraser Nelson editor of The Spectator
and we always reckon that each magazine
is read by about two or three other
people where people give it to their
family members their friends when they
finished reading it the magazine can get
passed around but probably not very much
right now in this era of self-isolation
so we decided that for those who would
normally read the magazine but might not
get a copy now we have asked our
Economist's to read out some of their
work so for this week's magazine we have
Douglas money Tania gold and mark Mason
here's Douglas Murray - start below the
crisis a question floats where do we
find purpose by Douglas Murray perhaps
we are at least past the beginning of
this crisis the phase where the hunt for
multi packs of loo rolls briefly became
the national sport now we are into the
second perhaps even less glorious stage
in which we all have to sit in our
solitude and hope that the storm blows
over us and if this passivity is the
great demand of our generation a demand
that brings its own ironies then now is
a good time to ask the question how do
we spend our time well the question is
one we ought to ask more throughout our
lives but the truth is that most of us
tend to ask it only at moments of
personal crisis when a job or
relationship suddenly ends or a loved
one dies by asking how do we spend our
time well I do not
of course means simply how do we keep
ourselves busy there are home exercise
videos for that even DIY if you must
I mean how ought we to use this time
meaningfully an immediate urge will be
ought to be to hold our loved ones close
or at least as close as we can in an era
in which we cannot hold them we will
satisfy the need to call each other more
wave to each other more and leave
supplies even luxuries where we can and
if this crisis provides a surge in the
strength of our networks of friends and
family then that is no small boon to
stockpile even an engagement diary as
empty as the roads can be rescued I have
taken to arranging virtual drinks with
friends diary in them in as I would in
normal times so I have drinks or tea if
the air is not yet six a rule especially
worth adhering to now with friends
around the world and I might remark that
as all drinkers know bringing your own
booze always ensures the best party
family and friendship are not small
things and certainly not during these
days but still the question exists at a
level beneath that where do we find
purpose there were many oddities about
the world that was ours but one of the
oddest was that it chose to leave this
question essentially unaddressed partly
this was a product of the liberal story
of emancipation which proclaimed that we
were getting freer and freer but never
said what we were meant to do once we
had all this freedom other than to be
ourselves or find meaning where you will
there is a lot to be said for find
meaning where you will certainly it is
better than somebody else trying to
impose their idea of meaning
you but it is still a radically
different thing from a message that says
and there is meaning during recent years
much of our society found a purpose and
a kind of meaning in politics even at
the time that period seemed curious it
was a period in which people who had no
connection to the media felt that they
needed to absorb minute by minute
updates on everything it was an age in
which watches would beep phones would
buzz and tablets would ping with updates
on things that few of us could affect
and mostly wouldn't affect us but it
gave a purpose of a kind world's away
though they seemed now the stop brexit
and stop Trump crowds and their
opposites had a distractingly busy few
years and if they didn't find meaning in
the deepest sense as in what I would
look at with pride on my deathbed
they certainly found some of the best
simulaid forums around there is a risk
that this virus also becomes something
to do a thing which however well or
badly we ride it out absorbs almost all
of our time thoughts and energies the
temptation is there in the regular news
conferences and announcements each day
brings new figures to absorb new
comparisons to make between countries
he'll we've even had that hangover
discussion about what to call the virus
and whether referring to its origins is
racist on art absorption in some or all
of these things has already come to
constitute a full-time job for many
people and I will say nothing about the
number of undercover viola gist shooters
out to have been living among us all
these years still the question lingers
what ought we to be doing both during
and after this crisis I would expect the
political left to once again prove their
ability to provide narratives and
explanations
doubtless at some point they will
declare a great mission and perhaps it
will have its attractions a call to have
more doctors or care workers for
instance or an insistence that since we
were all equal in the Amaze of the virus
so we should be made more equal in other
ways to parts of the political right
will bang their own ideological drums
they will talk about the markets and
much more as if everything did not just
change radically in the era to come who
knows which of these people we will want
to listen to if any as a writer I might
claim to have been in training for this
moment all my life solitude and silence
have been agreeable indeed vital
companions to me and to that extent
recent days have not been that different
from any others apart from performing
the new chores we all must carry out I
spend my days as I always do at home
inside I migrate between my writing desk
and piano I enjoy the garden more and
yet in the gaps that have opened up the
bigger question hovers I suppose my own
answer is a doctrine of a kind which is
that we are most likely to find meaning
in the places where meaning has been
found before that what has seen our
forebears through and nourished them
will see us through and nourish us in
turn I don't listen to the news March if
the church is open I will sit in it i
remake my acquaintance with great music
in the evenings I read Anna Karenina
that was Douglas Murray and here's
tenure goals about the increasingly
sensitive politics in Cornwall the
Cornish revolt against second homeowners
they are not welcome in times of
pandemic by tangled it was sunny on
Monday so I took the children swimming
in Mazel Harbor was almost empty but a
woman sanding a boat on the key side
scale
me she couldn't hear the children's
Cornish accents which might tell her
that I live here
there have been tensions for years
between native Cornish and the incomers
who buy houses and draped them with
nautical themed junk with endemic they
have developed into hostility a sign
appeared on the bus stop in Mazel if you
have travelled from a hotspot area
outside Cornwall like London you are
putting vulnerable people in this
village at risk of death please come
back when the virus peak has passed
until then travel is selfish and unkind
but it was grey and windy that day and
the sign blew away tourism brings 1.8
billion pounds a year to Cornwall and
employs one in five people tin mining
has gone and fishing is declining so the
Cornish usually greet in comers Emmet's
or ants with phlegmatic grace but not
when there is a pandemic an aging
population widespread ill health an only
one major hospital at risk Cornwall has
15 critical care beds to serve a
population of more than half a million
they had to release impatience after
going over capacity in January they
won't confirm the numbers of critical
care beds available now they don't want
to frighten people it's too late for
that it is widely believed that there is
a case of coronavirus in Penzance and
another incident just the most westerly
town in Britain as I write there are at
least 25 cases in seven deaths as I
speak there are at least 37 cases and
seven deaths it is also widely believed
that the route of infection is second
home owners still we do our best grocers
deliver to vulnerable people for free we
share information on where food is
plentiful saints British still out of
flour what are they doing with it but
there is still plenty at thorns fruit
and vege in long run there is fear but
not despair Cornwall has known misery
before she is used to relying on herself
in 1595 the Spanish landed and
bernoullian Mauser land Penzance by the
time the militia arrived from Plymouth
they had sailed away when the schools
closed we believed that people wouldn't
come for Easter holidays the leader of
Cornwall Council
visit Cornwall from the MP force and
auslan nuki asked people not to come so
did the professional mermaid Laura Evans
but that counts for nothing
photographs of long queues on the a30
were published with aghast comments mark
Jenkin
who last month won the BAFTA for
outstanding British debut forbade a film
about gentrification in Cornwall posted
please don't come to Cornwall we don't
have the resources for us let alone new
bait has a dark ending but any sequel
may be darker
gentrification has not so far led to
mass death it is usually more grumbling
and looks baits starred rosette
holidaying in Cornwall for the
foreseeable future under the current
circumstances could have a catastrophic
impact for the people that live and work
here bait star Edie roof said holidaying
in Cornwall for the foreseeable future
under the current circumstances could
have a catastrophic impact for the
people that live and work here he quoted
a doctor a true lisp who simply said
don't come here the holiday cottages are
largely empty responsible owners ask
guests to come later in the year despite
the impact on their business holiday
parks were pressure to close sometimes
with death threats but the owners of
second homes are here ordering hundreds
of pounds of groceries for delivery I
went to some barriers where Straw Dogs a
very rude film about Cornish violence to
income as starring Dustin Hoffman was
filmed to buy sausages at the farm shop
I saw Londoners in clean barbers and
shiny land rivers staring at frozen
pasties on the way home I saw a Bentley
I wondered if there were pasties in the
boot a Mazal resident told me and that
he spoke to me a person who has only
lived here for three years is by itself
unusual it's busier than it would
normally be at this time out and about
today there are strange faces using the
shop in the deli it's the same instant
Ives I ever heard one woman say on the
phone she hadn't realised the hostility
the long-term locals are really quite
upset they are trying to protect their
own health I think they're feeling
threatened it was worse instant just but
it is a tough place wants a mining
boomtown with a population for a while
large in the Manchester stories which I
think are lies but they don't bother to
deny tell that they throw unpleasant
incomes down mine shafts but only after
a proper warning has been ignored they
are Hardy incent just even if the
Cornish I was told that a resident
approached a second homeowner have you
seen the guidance on non-essential
travel no so what well you're not really
supposed to be here it's my bloody house
and it's our bloody Hospital is that a
proper warning now they're threatening
not to sell food to the Emmet's
they will be lynched said the local
butcher calmly but in the end there was
no time for lynching
the Duchy isn't locked down but the
Isles of Scilly acted early because they
are used to peril for British warships
and 1,300 men were lost there in 1707
with their Admiral Sir Klaus Li shovel
the pub dog and the Admiral Benbow in
Penzance is named for him the Isles
didn't wait for the government
the solonian which sails daily bought
college kids and local residents home
before they announcement of lockdown on
Monday others were not allowed to board
that was tenure gold and finally mark
Mason notes on working from home by mark
Mason working from home has been on the
rise for years no one expected the
latest surge to happen in the way it has
but now that we're here what can we
learn about home working from those
who've already done it the first rule
even when times are normal is make sure
you stay at home Victor Hugo resisted
the temptation to go out by ordering his
valet to hide all his clothes the Greek
statesman demosthenes achieved the same
result by shaving half of his head
whenever he felt the need for exercise
Cardinal Richelieu jumped over his
furniture but even at home the scope for
procrastination is endless any writer
will tell you that the first result of a
deadline is your ironing gets done so
you need a routine the good news is that
unlike in the office you can create your
own honoré de Balzac rose at midnight
and worked until dawn when he treated
himself to an hour-long bath the latter
element was copied from Napoleon
although Balzac also channeled a to
Ronnies he worked at a desk lit by four
candles another good thing is that you
can take your time to get things right
improving your work gradually rather
than aiming for perfection first time as
PG Woodhouse finished each page of a
book he was writing he would pin it to
his office wall at a height indicating
how good it was
pages still needing work were lower down
and after being rewritten would make
their way upwards the idea was to get
the whole manuscript up to the picture
rail food is tricky you can use it as an
incentive the snooker player Steve Davis
allowed himself a cheese and Marmite
sandwich only after potting a certain
number of balls in practice but too much
incentivization will threaten your
waistline mind you the opposite problem
can also arise Isaac Newton's sometimes
concentrated so hard on his
that he forgot about his dinner and the
cat ate it keep an eye on your caffeine
levels it's a good idea to use a small
cup rather than a mug most of the time
you're only making coffee as work
avoidance rather than because she really
wanted learn from Tony Benn whose mug
held a pint of tea he drank a mug per
hour and ended up in hospital with Polly
neuritis one advantage of working from
home is that you won't have to put up
with irritating colleagues although you
might start to find that you need them
as grist to your creative mill in this
case follow the lead of henrik ibsen
you had a portrait of august strindberg
facing his desk i cannot write a line
said Epson without that madman standing
and staring down at me with his mad eyes
inspiration can come in many forms
hilary Mantell counters writer's block
by taking a shower Albert Einstein
solved tricky problems by playing the
violin as he contemplated them or you
could take an afternoon nap Winston
Churchill favoured them claiming they
allowed him to pack 36 hours work into
only 24 Ronald Reagan was another fan
however the president left orders to be
woken in case of an emergency even if
I'm in a cabinet meeting that was mark
Mason and that's it for the podcast this
week if you have any thoughts on the
forum s because we kind of just made
this one up then do email us and podcast
at spectator dort co dot uk'
thanks for listening and thanks to our
producer Cindy you
[Music]